посмішки 2014 року після катастрофи
малайзійського боїнгу в успадковує як і
заглянула 298 людей російської
міноборони представила на простому
форматі кіль касу мандрівників їх знімків
але одне можна їх готова на музу версію
міністерство 17 мл та пня біля району
населеного пункту за roshen тику можна
побачите 2 українську зенітно-ракетну
комплекс ebook злитися на думку
російської сторони з рукава ним
дальності стрільби українська вся кава
магли і збут і боїнг на ньому шуму за
бродіння знятому в тому ж районі данина
тому зірка букв уже вид судні команда
з 10 експертів ресурсу журналістських
розслідувань болін код проаналізував
від розминки представлю не російським
міністерством to die йшла виставка що за
бродіння був і графічного бро плані у
фотошопі за допомогою методу аналізу
ременя по крейдах фахівці виявили що
на знімках був і туди не декі елементи
на одному хмари на енчу muse високу йому
вірністю ракетні комплекси 21 посмішка
2014 року міністерства оборони
Російської Федерації поставала святою
її спиною і відра доходу немає вона я
правда його готова не супу внукові знімка
і готові рахунок дзвонова тета українська
армію в катастрофи mh17 для аналізу ваші
знімки naco зображені український бог
команді експорті вдалося зупинити їх
що їх був ян чи пні amoi ж на місяць
раніше такого виставка ван Едішн і
що прийняв руслан і покривши ту структуру
по верхній території наших мандрівників і
знімках сервісу google plus ну мені
здається вона не здається рахунок риба з css
примати в контексті інформативної провини та
квд росія і я кремль на брудиться
обдурити і
а був просто запутати та публіку
заплутати публіку
пройшли думки bellingcat викл близько у
західних змій великий та resonance що
правда вже за кілька днів після його
публікації ранку сверблячки лише фахівців
кут осі аналізу графічних зображень
ви слова лісу мені в приводі точності
професіоналізм у тебе експорт і так
званий
аналіз ременя
акція суб'єктивні методи я звик
арештовують любить або винний навик
вам крем того друк аналізу знімки
спіру битники bellingcat зовсім треба
потрібно ж дріт відстані
програми ви на поліролі на владу не
інтерпретації та порушивши все потужними fact
it off козявка
у ти хто засовує подібний метод ви
якийсь занадто великий простір для
інтерпретацій з виразом на кого її
густіше
знаковою точкою зору на результати
такого аналізу можна траплятися на думку
йенса кріса за повагу до застосування
photoshop розум це даних знімках нічого
треба подати
а російська сторона могла б
червоний photoshop на приклад для до
дування текстових за ясною а я до відра
бувало накрита q владний творці свиту
за коментарем вивернулась дата meal і
на ці brow частиною розробка мережевого
проекту відомому вона не має жадібних сум
ними з приводу компетентності на
кризом вин професіонал аналіз
графічних зображень свого робота
ще правда мене виник вираз з
Чино суду пам'ять на цю читала до кінця
головний аргумент криза на і кумарин
базову критику цілий хор зі ста
методу аналізу рівня допоміг проте cm
цей вікна нею спливаючи на головний ви
знову до нашого розслідування ще на
середньому як у казані не правою не датою
поп'є 1 критих і поважає пари до
новим цей курив я несу мандрівникам у і
знімками на даному ресурсом зате по
моєму якову баленко tv100 новий у чому
Міноборони Росії видав дуже рівну
вагою мандрівник ув'язнемо кай залип на яві
фольгою проблема в тому, що google
укладається на посту чайники а он і
надають у краще знаки страти kill частини
шиза всі база значення точної дати
коливаний і були рабами і ноги може і все
про вартовий крім куди і криками city
про тему виставляєте вище одна дата на
сизо бродіння зняти і зачепили lahnstein
що правда експерти bellingcat на полях
тиснути на точності чогось методу і на тому
що дати на знімках google чи ми маємо право
будемо кому хіба духовному наші свято
цей маккей підтвердити що на знімках
на даних google
у казані правої не дати ми доведемо
циклів
оригінальні супутникові фотографії
треба заводжу 1000-го на душу дорозі
життя муки краз
за 17 років все допомогти очистки по так
і він ти міккі представила міністерство
оборони Росії
чиним маркус бенсманн reporter бюро
журналістських розслідувань correctiv
ви вирішивши на покладу тис а треба що
низку мандрівника ви їх знімків
ми накладали to win the його кулагін
ізотову після трагедії врятував і в село
сорочинська об камінь там я поговорив і
smash кінці ми сила тексти ми хто
виступав проти сепаратистів таки стем
їх то їх петром і всі ми не сказав ще
того дня за його районом ніхто не
стріляв ще того дня 17 посмішка 2014
у поліни було ніяких буде октін хаш
than детально несу мандрівнику we знімку
російську сторону учень незабаром джавс
астани одразу мило ж ужев не to die
будуть опубліковані
залишкові результати офіційного
розслідування катастрофи боїнгу мн17